hello and welcome to PlayStation granade
December is here the last chance for
game publishers to take advantage of the
Christmas sales around 20 high quality
games released this month with the most
iconic being Super Smash Bros ultimate
on the switch but as a PlayStation PC or
Xbox owner there are others that are
worth your attention here's seven of
them player unknowns battlegrounds are
pub G as the cool kids safe is finally
jumping over to the ps4 this month on
December 7th to be precise if you're not
in the loop let me break it down pub G
was one of the first battle royale
titles around and definitely the first
to take over the world in terms of
twitch streaming and hype you know the
deal 100 players parachute down and
shoot the living hell out of each other
until only one survives but G has been
eclipsed by fortnight over the last year
but now it feels the game is in the
perfect place on console to finally go
after the ps4 players will this be the
right adversary for fortnight or even
Call of Duty's black out let me know in
the comments and if you like me to
upload some gameplay just give me a
shout
Just Cause 4 is releasing on December
the 4th on Xbox ps4 and PC three years
after the last iteration which I
personally absolutely loved playing as
Rico Rodriguez and blowing it up has
always been the highlight of the game
but the grappling hook and wingsuit set
to just cause apart from other
open-world adventure titles this time
Rico is taking on the black hand the
world's most powerful private army
Just Cause 4 has a few new innovations
to boast first it has improved AI which
will think tactically and attempt to
flank your position and use cover where
possible the second innovation is damn
impressive extreme weather effects from
blizzards to sandstorms has even
functioning tornados to play with but
Just Cause series has always run better
on PC than console so if you're a bit
unsure I understand completely Just
Cause 3 in particular had pretty
worrisome issues when first released on
Xbox and ps4 I'll do my best to get my
hands on it too so check back next week
for some gameplay Newton is 0 wrote to
Eden is yet another title worth your
time in December on ps4 Xbox and PC this
is a turn-based tactical combat title
which is heavily inspired by the XCOM
series
a bit like a game of chess don't get me
wrong it can feel frantic and rushed in
areas but generally combat is low and
time is given to think about the moves
before you take them added on to this is
a real-time stealth element allowing our
heroes to find the perfect spot on the
battlefield before attacking enemies
real-time stealth in a turn-based
shooter the innovation is definitely
here the story is centered around life
after humanity on earth everything is in
ruins and you've probably noticed that
we're playing as mutant animals like a
boar and a duck hmm what markers you
want mutant Year Zero wrote to Eden lund
on December 4th on ps4 PC and Xbox over
on PSV are another great title appears
Borderlands 2 VR I haven't played this
one so I can't talk about it from that
position but I have played and completed
bottle unto about eleven times over the
last decade and if this is more of the
same than vandeman bought there are some
perplexing decisions to note though most
evidently the lack of cooperative play
in a game renowned for playing with
others that's such a shame because
taking on hunt and Jack with a friend
could have made this game unmissable but
time will tell I suppose Borderlands 2
VR will support warp to move mechanics
to prevent motion sickness and releases
on December the 14th here's a quirky one
that will likely receive no attention
from major gaming publications this is
override mech city brawl the glory days
of mech warfare may be behind us but it
overrides nostalgia an innovative
approach to smashing the hell out of
other robots is surprisingly appealing
with a dozen mechs to choose from taller
than the skyscrapers beside them oh and
speaking of those cities beside them
Tokyo San Francisco Mexico and even
Egypt make appearances as destructible
levels customization allows for mechs to
feel unique and the multiplayer modes
are the icing on the cake one in
particular the party co-op game where up
to four friends can control different
elements and limbs of the same mech
allowing for some hilarious moments
override mech city brawl arrives on
December the 4th let's be sure to cover
a piece of DLC this month this time is
from Assassin's Creed Odyssey the first
installment of a three-part tale begins
in December over in Macedonia the legacy
of the hidden blade the real star
doubt point about this DLC is the facts
that will be controlling the first ever
person to harness the hidden blade truly
historic in terms of gameplay it's more
of the same but people like that so
there's nothing wrong with it there's
conflicting reports on the release date
so I'll take a random stab in the dark
at December the 18th and finally
fortnight season 7 yeah I know what
you're gonna say it's time to forget
about fortnight Adam I'm not ready to
let it go yet okay season seven will
likely be the Christmas themed update to
the game world so snow will fall
there'll be a whole new battle pass to
grind through and festive themed items
to loot and buy okay I'll stop I won't
go on about fortnight anymore so there
we have it seven new games DLCs and
updates you should be aware of over
December 2018 give me a shout if you
want me to play any of these titles on
the channel I'm Adam from Playstation
grenade it's been a pleasure I'll see
you next time
[Music]